[Music]
Christian
for
w
[Music]
just
Happ
hey
everybody hey Shiloh so hey sa so good
to see y'all uh thanks for being here if
you're online thanks for joining us
online um it's kind of a dreary day any
might get any work done today I didn't I
stayed at home and just kind of lounged
around um yeah thanks for being here we
have a few announcements before we get
started tonight uh coming up there's a
day kids you might know this what is the
day December 24th y'all know what that
is don't know what that is okay
Christmas Eve right so on Christmas Eve
we're going to have our Christmas Eve
service here and it's going to be at
4 it's not going to be at 5: like we
normally meet on Sunday nights it is
going to be at 400 PM
so well that's coming up but we're not
doing anything for
Thanksgiving so four o'clock on December
24th that will be our Christmas Eve
service and we hope to see everybody
there also coming up before that is uh
on December 10th if you are interested
in the table if you're interested in
becoming a member finding out what we're
doing where we're going we have a class
called Welcome to the table it will be
right after the service on December 10th
uh and I think we meet just right next
door in this room so if that's something
you're interested in you want to know
more about what we're what we're doing
and what we're about please join us on
December 10th
and questions and answers are after the
whole
thing is that okay is that all right
maybe after I'll get you in a
minute I love that the kids are up front
and a part of the start of the service
right that's cool all right well uh man
the holidays are coming up and uh this
time of year tends to get like super
crazy we all kind of run around our
heads cut off right chickens with their
heads cut off uh so I just want to take
a moment tonight uh before we get
started just to kind of pause be in some
silence and uh some deep thought maybe
not even deep thought just kind of rest
your thoughts for a little bit uh
because if you're anything like me
you're just go go go go go and uh it's
important to be able to just sit in
Solace so uh if you just kind of want to
close your eyes you can bow your head if
you want uh or just sit
there take in some deep
breaths
consider the community that you're in
right
now how am I thankful for the people
here how are the people here thankful
for
me put all the worries of the week
behind and just kind of
sit in silence with
[Music]
God
father may you move us tonight in the
words spoken in the song
sung may you rest our hearts from the
hustle and bustle of everyday life may
we sit and reflect in
thankfulness
thanks Josh would you guys stand with us
we're going to open up with music and um
I just hope that tonight you know like
Josh was saying I've just been recently
reminded how grateful I am for each one
of you and the ways that God has kind of
woven this community together um and
last week I was sitting in the service
and as Brett was sharing I just felt
like tears kind of like welling up in my
eyes and like a lump in my throat and it
can be so easy sometimes to like get
into the routine of what we do um and
for me you know there's a lot of like
little tasks that I'm trying to remember
on a Sunday night for the music and all
the different things going on but
sitting at the back of the room last
Sunday it was just like this deep sense
of gratitude um for you guys and I hope
that tonight as we worship together as
we're connecting with Spirit God with
love with this sense of um renewal and
um just the goodness of a father and a
mother God who loves us and calls us
forward I hope that in the midst of that
you also are feeling surrounded by the
love of a community who sees you and um
and is grateful for you in this space so
um that is church right it's the
connection it's the connections so um
anyway I just wanted to say thank you
guys thanks for showing up thanks for
making this meaningful for me um and for
all of us we are richer and better
together so Vicki's given me the peace
sign going to take that as our entrance
into song number one Jesse's going to
get us started so you guys join in as
you
[Music]
can when darkness tries to roll over my
bones
when sorrow comes to steal the joy I
own when Brokenness and pain is all I
know I won't be
Shen no I won't be
[Music]
Shen my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear doesn't
stand a change
when I stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand In
Your
[Music]
Love shame no longer has place to
hide and I am not a captive to the
[Music]
lies I'm not not afraid to leave my past
behind that I won't be
Shen no I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand the chance
when I stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your love my fear doesn't stand the
chance when I'm stand in your
[Music]
love break
every
[Music]
outre there power in your name power in
your
there's that break off every
chain there's power that can empty out
gra there's
resurrection power that can
save power in your name power in your
name my fear doesn't stand
I
[Music]
stand fear stand chance I stand in your
love my fear doesn't stand chance when I
stand in your
[Music]
love my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear does it
stand a chance when I stand in your love
my fear does stand the chance when I
stand in your
[Music]
love all right kiddos y'all are
dismissed to go your CL rooms and if
anyone missed our kids worker that was
outside today we are actually not able
to use the nursery due to the leak that
Pleasant Valley experience so our
Nursery is going to be with our
preschooler kids so all the way up
through first grade will be in this room
right here and then of course second
through sixth is to my right so thank
you kids ministry workers for making the
adjustment we appreciate you
guys
we're going to move into the prayers of
the
people so let's take a deep breath and
let's read this aloud together and um
then we'll leave space for each of you
um to share a name or a situation out
loud um and then we'll finish the prayer
out together as
well Jesus for the city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you for those without a family upcoming
holiday
[Music]
season
Tel for the names and moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen
God we bring you the work of
our now lay it down
lay
your we've what we buil what we
broken lay it down lay it your
feet you hold it all Jesus you
[Music]
hold worried Hearts wearied hands ween
body
lay it down lay it at your
feet what we've used what we lost what
we
wasted lay it down lay it your
feet you hold it oh Jesus you
hold
all you hold
it Jesus you hold
it all our dreams all our plans
our lay it down lay it at
your and even if nothing comes to
fruition lay it down lay it at your
feet lay it down lay
it your
[Music]
feet
I've carried a
bir for too long on my
[Music]
own I wasn't
cre to be it
[Music]
alone I he
invitation
to let it all
go I see it now I'm laying it down and I
know that I need you around to the
father a your gra I'm done with the
hiding no reason away my heart needs a
Sur and my soul needs a f
so I run to the father again and again
and again and
[Music]
again you saw my
condition had a plan from the
start you your son for
[Music]
Redemption the price for my
heart and I don't have a
[Music]
cont for that kind of love I don't
understand I can't
comprehend all I know is I need you run
to the
father I fall into Grace I'm done with
the hiding no reason to way my heart
needs a Sur my soul needs a friend so I
run to the father again and again and
again and
again
wo
wo again and
again
oh my heart has been in your sides long
before my first breath running
into
your arms he's running to life from
death I feel this Rush deep in my chest
Mercy is
calling out just as I am you pull
me and I know I need you now I run to
the I fall into Grace I'm done with the
hiding no reason to wait my heart needs
a Sur my soul needs a friend so I run to
the father again and again I run to the
father I fall into Grace I'm done with
the hiding the reason to wait my heart
found a Sur my soul found a friend so I
run to the far father again and again
and again and
again
oh
oh again and
again
oh
oh again and
again again and
[Music]
again
again God would you help our anxious
tendency to grab on to
control to speed
up to push away the honest moments to
push away way the real difficult
feelings the things we don't want to
face would you help us to
resist that and instead lean into
honesty with
you lean into
Stillness into
trust into
[Music]
surrender
God would you meet us in that
place in the
quiet in our
[Music]
fears would you hold
us where we're
scared where nothing does seem to be
coming to fruition where all of our best
efforts are still not
enough would you hold us tight
there and would we trust you to keep
leading us forward to keep seeing us
through to being our safe
place our
refuge our
home thank you for being a good God God
who loves
us and who is with us it's in your name
we
pray
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you say hello make them feel
welcomed and then Brett is going to get
us started with our
message nice job
Grace and peace it is so good to be with
you all um my name is Brett and uh yeah
it's just it's a joy to worship with you
a joy to be here with you and um that is
uh true for those joining us online as
always love yall lots and uh also I want
to give another shout out to James
Townsen who's on there week after week
after week uh being our kind of online
uh kind of what would be the term not
moderator but really more of like a
community facilitator and really
grateful for James and also um really
grateful for anyone here tonight who is
new um thank you for for being Among Us
uh I know what that can kind of feel
like um not here so much but when I
visit other places I know that feeling
you know of going into the new space
you're just like oh and so um just yeah
thank you for for being here um with us
so uh tonight we're kind of in between
Series this week next week we'll be kind
of in between um we'll eventually get
into Advent uh in two weeks as we kind
of prepare for the Christmas season um
but
tonight is uh the title of the message
is silence and the two
minds and this uh this message like it's
honestly I wrestled with it so much it's
a bit of an odd message I realized I
wrote far too much um and even after
edit this this is version five I don't
have time for version five you know when
you're doing anything every week it's
like you don't got you just got to roll
with it you know friend um but I really
and my heart is just with this message I
care about it so much um but I worry a
that I'll go way too long and B that I
might um might lose people and I don't
you know that's I never want to do that
where uh I'm just like blowing ahead and
people like what are you talking about
you know that's that's like bad sign as
a pastor so um it's really help kind of
going in this message just to give you a
heads up if you've done any kind of um
what I'll call like a practice of
Silence if you have ever taken time like
kind of extended time even like in
prayer um where maybe you're not saying
so much you know our prayers can often
be very wordy um and that's fine there's
a place for that certainly um but if
you've ever just taken time for just
quiet you know uh and and seeing what
happens in the mind when you do that you
will probably the more you've done that
the more you will be able to track if
you haven't so much that's okay
hopefully this can still be kind of like
I don't know something you can glean
something and maybe will even inspire
you towards um some of that so Al to say
if you're wondering um why I'm kind of
like sticking so close to my notes
that's why I want to like stay clear as
clear as I can on this one um and then
you know in the future I'll wander a
little bit more but not today so um our
passage is actually a really short one
uh it is from psalm 16
uh chapter
16:8 which says I keep my eyes always on
the Lord with him at my right hand which
in the scripture is um almost always an
illusion to Authority when a king would
sit you know someone would sit at their
right hand uh with him at my right hand
um I will not be
shaken so back in uh High School I read
a book that was very formative for me um
maybe I've mentioned it before although
I think it's been a while um it's called
the practice of the presence of God by a
French monk has anyone read this this
book uh I mean it's super tiny um
wonderful wonderful book it's by a
French monk named um well he's from like
the 16th century named brother Lawrence
is the the kind of um name they gave him
when he entered the monastery and he was
only the cook at this Monastery so you
know he didn't have like extensive
theological training uh he was not a
renowned preach
something you know he I know he was like
just the cook you know um however over a
number of decades he developed what he
called um a practice of the presence of
God the way he put it is that um when he
found that his mind had drifted from God
you might say kind of entered a state of
distraction you know he would um just
bring it back to God and in this way he
kind of um
he said that the sense of the presence
of the Lord began to kind of envelop him
even carry him so to speak he said for
example um whenever he had like a task
to do uh perhaps as often as a cook he
had to like go into town and purchase
you know large amounts of food and wine
and whatever for the monastery um that
he would kind of go into it and he would
simply say he could be a little anxious
about it so he would say simply just
Lord you know that uh apart from you I
can't do a darn thing right and so I I
simply entrust myself to
you may your presence lead me and then
he would just go through and just
conduct the business and over and over
he found like things it just kind of
things happened for
him and he said in this way he learned
that this sense of kind of an of ongoing
communion um ongoing trust and surrender
to the Lord what he called a practice of
his presence um kind of began to develop
in him and with it came all the fruits
of the spirit spirit that we talk about
a lot here at the table uh love and joy
and peace and patience and you know and
so on and so forth and in fact he did
like he wasn't just kind of delusional
so among like thinking oh I've developed
this presence of the Lord but he's like
whatever um no no people actually began
to travel from around he became known as
like a very um just a good man a holy
person uh someone that could be
trusted and um gone to for wisdom even
Bishops would visit him for
perspective and people could tell there
something about him was was different
now when I read this little book like
something in my high school Brett heart
left and I said oh my goodness here is
like a Christianity not just in in books
or even just in the Bible but here's a
life lived and I too like I wanted that
sense of God's presence um I wanted that
peace and that love and that Joy
uh but even after reading and rereading
the book I had to admit that I didn't
quite know what brother Lawrence was
getting at like I thought he was
saying think about God a
lot uh like see because even his
language is a little tricky because he'd
say things like let God never leave your
mind can you see where I would get
confused like let God never leave your
mind I get it okay God Jesus Holy Spirit
Lord you know just I guess that's what
you know what it means uh which of
course I found utterly impossible like
how am I supposed to live my life and
think about God all at the same time you
know just like this this can't be done
um and so it wouldn't be until many many
years later that I began to understand
uh that in the same way Psalm 168 keep
your eyes all always on the Lord does
not mean to
literally look for God in your day you
know um in the same way pray without
ceasing from first Thessalonians it's
chapter 4 um does not mean literally 247
say verbal prayers to God so practice
the presence of the Lord does not mean
think about God a lot or recite Bible
verses in your head every chance you get
uh and
instead not that that's bad you know but
but instead these are poetic statements
pointing towards what we might call the
orientation of one's
attention it's statements like that
where I worry I'll lose
people um so hang with me because um I
know that needs some unpacking in
essence the rest of the message will
kind of do do that hope hopefully um and
at times it may seem like we've moved on
from from Psalm 16 but um just trust we
have not the whole message is is about
these things
um so let me let me kind of come back to
something there's uh a movie I adore my
wife watched it first and then she told
me I have to watch it and then but I
didn't and then my friend Jesse watched
it and he's like dude seriously you have
to watch this movie and finally I did it
sound of metal um has anyone seen this
one bonus points if you have both read
practice of the presence of the Lord and
watch the movie sound of metal every
Christian is quite a statement every
Christian much watch watch sound of
metal um incredible so basically the
story goes um it's about a heavy metal
drummer and a former addict named Reuben
who loses his hearing and is
plunged into a life of
silence and at first what he thinks is
killing him
ultimately is his
salvation as he begins to come to grips
with this great silence I'm
intentionally kind of leaving it vague
because I want you to see it and then
kind of see how it all unfolds and plays
out um now the first time you watch the
film you will there's like a pro tip you
will probably think to yourself I get it
this is a movie about a heavy metal
drummer named named uh Reuben who loses
his hearing and is plunged into silence
and what at first he thinks is killing
him is actually his
salvation um but no um that's not okay
that's a little bit of an overstatement
I mean of course at one level that's
totally what the movie is about but at a
deeper level you know what I think it's
about I think it's about
us like I think it's a parable of the
modern world that we live in a societ
Society who through technology and
productivity and materialism and
advertising and at first radio and then
television and now streaming services
how many streaming services do you have
and cell phones and buzzing texts and
dinging
notifications and traffic and and just
work that has us going going going and
achieving and striving I think we are
all
Reuben we're plunged into noise just
words words words noise noise noise
plunged into thinking thinking thinking
analyzing figuring
striving you might say that are you
anxious yet
uh I did that on purpose rhetorically
all right um right like and I think our
tension is a mess and I don't just mean
like we're we're we're multitaskers and
we're trying to do too I mean that's
true but um I think again I think it's
it's deeper than that Anglican writer
and theologian Maggie
Ross um in her wonderful book um which
I'll talk about at the end um says this
she says the world is out of joint not
only because from a cultural standpoint
of view our bodies have been cut off
from our
minds just one of many consequences of
our having lost a relationship with a
natural world for example just think of
anytime you sit down on a computer for
like seven hours it's like you forget
you have a
body you know that's a good perfect
example um she say but it's not only
that but also because our minds
overloaded with extraneous information
and stressed by the frenetic speed
required merely to stay alive in our
artificial world have lost their
relationship with the original
Silence from which and within which we
evolved like just think of our ancient
ancestors and how much silence they
lived in I mean if you live before you
move to the cities and the development
of human culture and you know spent a
lot of time in the
woods
quiet she says silence is
essential to language Insight poetry in
music now you might think by all this
talk of Silence that Ross means only
like literal external silence like we
need more quiet you know and that is
part of her point but if you read her
book um silence a user's guide um you'll
see it's actually bigger than that
silence ultimately um and this connects
back to Psalm 168 and everything else
silence is is actually about
what the
mind that's the silence we need it's
about learning to rest and operate in
what we might call um what she calls
deep mind it's kind of the same thing um
right with Reuben in the movie sound of
metal where exterior silence the reason
he struggles is the same reason we
struggle because in exter like a a
silence in the world kind of forces us
back
where into the Mind
precisely where we never want to go amen
you know what I mean it's just like
anything I can do to avoid that in fact
now I'm leaving my notes I promis myself
won't do this I heard about a study
they're paying college students to um to
they could sit in a room alone I might
have mentioned this in previous sermon I
can't recall either definitely in an e
letter it made an e letter um to sit in
a room alone or they could shock
themselves and like it was something
like 60 to 70% of men it was only like
30 to 40% of women smarter I guess I
don't know um opted to shock themselves
over facing silence like I'd rather just
like something something anything right
now what's that
about because um well what the the call
there right you have to kind of face a
certain internal noise and then break
through that noise to an interior
silence that's like that's the
transition I think we but we never make
it there so we just think silence is the
worst right just like those college
students um to help explain this there's
a a wonderful um psychiatrist from
Oxford his name is Ian mcgilchrist he
wrote a book called The Master in his
Emissary um a really really profound
work about the two hemispheres of the
brain I think this to some degree maps
on to what we're talking about perhaps
not perfectly um but it's I think it's
always interesting when like
Neuroscience kind of connects with
things that um folks in spirituality and
religion have been talking about for
thousands of years and the scientists
you are always catching up which is cool
um so if you look at the brain right the
most obvious thing is that it has two
sides left hemisphere right hemisphere
connected by the Corpus colome um early
Research into this kind of went a little
too far it thought like oh perhaps the
two hemispheres do like totally
different things you know for example
like they speculated oh one side would
handle reason the other side emotion one
side handles logical thinking the other
handled creative thinking um but these
early researchers they were super
disappointed when they realized like no
actually both hemispheres are involved
in quite quite a bit um but um it was
actually McGill Christ though and he was
drawing on some research that they
realized like
well um don't give up on it though
because actually I mean if you look at
the brain it's obvious it's you know the
most obvious thing is that it's divided
so surely this has you know something to
do with something and what Migel Chris
names is um a very key difference is
really one of attention and awareness
how they attend to the world which is
really to say how we attend to the world
the left hemisphere is um very detail
oriented it's fixed on what is known
anytime you're like looking for
something you're like locked in on
that's very a very left hemisphere thing
to do whereas say you have a problem but
you don't know how to figure out what it
it is or with a solution your left himem
misphere has done all it can um have you
ever gone for a
walk and then suddenly what
happens the solution comes to you out of
nowhere like you weren't even thinking
about it but you were thinking about it
right it was the right hemisphere that
was doing the thinking we even have a
saying for this like oh you you need to
sleep on it just sleep on it you know
and we know it's a weird weird thing
it's like stuff just comes to us um in
fact um Albert Einstein was famous for
really appreciating the two
hemispheres um and of course he's super
smart he could use that left hemisphere
as needed but he knew for imaginative
leaps and insights you actually need to
open yourself up to other forms of
knowing and so mcgilchrist took the
title of his book from Einstein um you
see Einstein was worried that we're
living in a world where more and more of
our time and attention is shifting to
the left hemisphere only and we're
closing oursel off to that kind of
mysterious open awareness if the left is
sort of locked in the right is sort of
open to all things so Einstein said this
the intuitive mind that kind of Deep
Mind is a sacred gift and the rational
mind is a faithful servant we have
created a society that honors the
servant but has forgotten the gift
right in other words we're super left
hemisphere kinds of people always
thinking thinking thinking analyzing
figuring out problem solving like we
just live there in that mode um here's
Maggie Ross again she says the healing
and transfiguring aspects of this Deep
Mind become available to us only when
the self-conscious mind right think of
that left hemisphere the mind that
categorizes what happens to us into
experiences and bombards us with
continual interior chatter anyone ever
had some continual interior chatter
going on if you're human you have right
it's only when it's set aside in some
way by one-pointed meditation for
example or by a walk in the woods in
other words by shifting our attention
away from the distractions of daily life
to Stillness and
silence this is what is meant by
metanoid in the Bible the changing of
one's mind heart and life when we turn
towards silence we can receive the
fruits of Deep Mind through insights
through changed perspective through the
mysterious healing that takes place out
of our sight the light from within can
burst upon us at just about any time we
give it an opening and we need to
realize that the depth of this hidden
greater part of the mind is where our
shared nature with God
indwells I think that's a really key
line and key idea I think we often
wonder how can I connect with
god um can you see that this is the
process it's an it's opening ourselves
in this way this is why Maggie Ross
contends every Christian alive today
must make the journey that Ruben's story
in sound of metal speaks to every
Christian we might say is called to the
journey away from the self-conscious
mind and towards the Deep Mind what
Jesus Calls the Heart where our shared
nature with God
indwells I think this kind of two minds
Paradigm completely opens up and
clarifies many scriptures that we might
read and be like um well maybe we might
think to ourselves that's like uh a very
cute thing a poetic thing a poetic
nicity but we have no idea what it's
talking about but actually this opens up
what it means even for example to have
faith right you might say um okay Faith
is I have this self-conscious left
hemisphere that thinks it's an absolute
genius and is in total control of
everything and is going to solve all of
my life problems by thinking and
analyzing but I'm going to begin to let
go of that I'm going to turn to the Lord
I'm going to trust
that the answers I need will come to me
that my next right step will be revealed
that the Lord will lead me what I love
about this perspective is that it
prevents keeping our eyes always on the
Lord or practicing his presence or
praying without ceasing or having the
mind of Christ from becoming another to
do right like where it's oh good now
Brett's giving us another thing another
spiritual practice I need to engage um
that would be to misunderstand instead
abide abiding in the Silence of Deep
Mind Is Not Another thing to do but a
way of doing
everything I think at its root the
practice would be something like this
when you catch yourself thinking I.E
lost an internal chatter often negative
in nature you begin to let those
thoughts go and you return to that
primordial
silence and you just do that over and
over and over again tikn not Han said
silence is ultimately something that
comes from the heart not from any set of
conditions outside us living from a
place of silence doesn't mean never
talking never engaging or doing things
it simply means that we are not
Disturbed inside there isn't constant
internal chatter
this has certainly proven true uh in my
own life what a miracle it was to
recognize that a big church would never
make me happy there was a time where I
thought that as superficial and silly as
it is to say that out loud but I I
really believe that um what a miracle it
was to realize that reading more books
wouldn't solve all of my problems
or having a bigger bank account would
not heal
me only meeting God in the depths of
this great
silence could do
that I'll close with this example from
my own life some of you know I run a
small super
cool side
business where I pick up dog
poop and uh I originally chose this um
very much on purpose um I I wanted it
well back to magur ras' idea of the body
and mind disconnect you know I spent a
lot of time on a computer you know
technology wanted something not that um
and so I chose this you know for that
reason I wanted to be kind of an outlet
for my practice of the presence of the
Lord I I wanted to do things that
naturally lint themselves to kind of
resting in that deep mind um but here's
the trick I wish I could say and then I
got out there scooping and oh and it was
just beautiful and I was just out in
nature and you know what happened on I
mean there were days were good um but I
had to learn cuz early
on um what I quickly found is that my
greed and my craving and and my just
self-conscious mind and I I mean that in
the most superficial sense like just we
tell teenagers like don't be so
self-conscious I just mean that mind you
know that's like worried about
everything um I realized it could turn
Heaven into hell
uh I can remember whole days lost where
I was out there I scoop for like six
hours on Fridays I was obsessed with
getting more clients I felt I needed
more clients and I needed them now and
so the whole time I'm out there I'm lost
in the hell of my left hemisphere why
can I not get more how can I get more
there must be some way think Brett think
think I mean it was figure it out come
on you idiot come on you're such a
failure look at you you're not even a
successful pooper scooper this is as low
as it gets my
friend and I was just
hours uh in
hell that's
the that's that mind you know it well I
don't I assume I'm not alone in this you
know uh but over time over time I'd
learned to rest in fact the more I
learned of this practice the more I
would realize Iz when I was in it and I
would have to keep Let It Go Brett and I
was like back to like oh my getting
pulled into it Let It Go
Just I needed to let it go let it you
know just back and forth but over time
over time I I realized really is life is
so simple in my case see the poop pick
up the poop uh rest in
Awareness like that's it I just I hear
the birds I see the grass and I come
home home I come back to my body I come
back to God I come back to this great
silence and on my best days it's
Heaven it's Heaven I even think of like
all the people inside their house when
I'm scooping and they're like in there
and maybe they're even miserable like
making way more money than I'm making
you know but I'm like so happy picking
up their dog piles you know um
it's a beautiful thing a few resources
um if you want to go deeper on this
silence a users's guide volume one by
Maggie Ross I can't vouch for volume two
I've read volume one I'm sure it's great
um silence the power of quiet in a world
full of Noise by tikot Han and then the
heart of Sinner In Prayer by Cynthia
Boral uh may all of us learn to keep our
eyes always on the Lord in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh come come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the
wine may we do it in a heart posture of
Silence when you find your mind's going
wherever it goes uh you just you just
bring it back and in this way I believe
Jesus begins to heal uh something within
us so the way we'll um take communion
tonight is we'll just start kind of on
the front row and we'll just work our
way back um we practice what's called an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you have a heart to
participate even if you're like what
denomination should I be this
denomination or that or do I need to
believe this or that or you know if
something in you wants to connect with
the Risen Jesus then you just come on
forward um the red is wine the white is
grape juice and then finally you can
just partake whenever you'd like um no
one will lead you through the exact
moment some people take it right away
some return to their seats and partake
there
so this is the table not of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you who
have much faith and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that the those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
I'm going to read
something
[Music]
as you guys finish up your communion um
I just wanted to share really quickly
we're g to we're about to do a new song
um that I've been listening to for a few
months and it's been such like life to
my dry bones but also extremely
convicting all at the same time um and I
just wanted to share a resource for you
especially in light of this specific
message there's a whole album that was
written by a group called The Porter
gate and the album is called worship for
workers and I feel like it has just done
an excellent job of pulling faith into
our everyday life and um creating
language and songs that help me to
connect um with the spirit of God in the
midst of my regular mundane work and
tasks and parenting and house cleaning
and all the things this specific song
that we're about to do is called slow me
down and for every song on the album
there's an piece of artwork that goes
with it that's just really beautiful I
meant to send that to our av team so
that they could put it up on the slide
for you guys and I totally forgot that's
on me but go look it up go look up
worship for workers by the porters gate
every song has artwork with it and a
meditation and a prayer that goes along
with it if you want it's just been such
a good resource for me to um have
another Avenue to kind of push my
spiritual disciplines um and before we
sing this song called slow me down I
just wanted to share a very small piece
of the prayer that they had written for
this
song um and there's more to it so go
look it up but it says God would you be
there to catch all that spills out when
I slow down catch my tears oh God
remember me when I
fall catch and remember in learning to
rest turn my grief into gratitude for
the sake of becoming more like you in
the fullness of humanity and
Divinity teach me to teach me today to
resist all the anxious toil that
produces bitter
fruit that just hit home for me the
anxious toil that produces bitter fruit
I am nothing if I am not
efficient I am so good at going fast I
run everywhere I go our friends give us
a hard time I love not wasting time and
I love
multitasking and these words and that
prayer I've just tried to let them like
seep into my bones and ask God to slow
me down so would you guys stand with us
as we sing this song I know it's going
to be new for most of us but the chorus
is very easy to catch on to and sing
along with and I just feel like as a
spiritual discipline let's close out our
service asking God to help us to slow
down to help us be quiet to help us
embrace the silence and the
Stillness
[Music]
oh good shepher would you teach me how
to
rest I'm rushing on will you make make
me to lie
down will you build a fold by the wat
that
refresh will you call my name and Le me
saely
out my anxious
stri to labor on and on
from the Restless
grind that has put my mind to
sleep will you call me back and gently
Slow Me
Down Will you show me now what to lose
and what to
keep oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
[Music]
Down when my tables bent with only GRE
and
gold and my grasping hands are afraid
you won't
provide Will you pour the wi that
loosens up
my set your table here with what Tru
satisfies
oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepherd oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me Down
on the busy streets trying to make
myself a
name if the work is yours there is
nothing you can
claim will you lead me home to the
pastures of your
peace if the house is yours I'm sitting
at your feet
oh good
shepherd oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepherd oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down Slow
[Music]
me thank you guys for joining us
uh thank you band that was a great set
tonight U you know for me music is is
that's my Avenue for silence is it it
moves me and it it kind of takes my
anxieties away and I'll just sit with
music uh this song that was incredible
thank you uh if you're new here tonight
thank you again for being here uh we'd
love to hear more about you we have a
small table in the uh fory year you can
fill out a card you can scan this QR
code uh and send it in um uh we just
like to get back in touch with you
answer any questions you have uh and uh
sorry I'm getting lost in the music so
I'm losing my train of thought here um
see it moves me that's what I'm saying
uh we have the new members class or the
welcome to the table class December 10th
so if it is something you're interested
in scan this QR code sign up and if you
have any questions about what we're
doing where we're going uh we'd love to
see you there
uh one thing that we do at the table is
we are committed to creating an
inclusive Christ centered community that
touches lives and to do that it does
take money so if you would like to join
us on this journey in giving you can
scan this code and it'll it'll take you
there steps you punch in some some
things and click some things and it'll
take you to the place you can give uh
monetary donations um we would love uh
to have you join us on that if you feel
moved to do so um I think that was
it sorry
guys it's not as smooth tonight for
[Music]
me last week I couldn't read this
because my contacts fogged up so I I
took a picture of it and I zoomed in so
now should be good I want to send you
guys out this week uh with a blessing so
if you want to open your hands up as a
sign of uh showing you're receiving a
blessing or open up your heart uh but
these words are for you as you go into
your
week you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go fill
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed you guys have
a great week we'll see you next
[Music]
Sunday oh good shepher
oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down Slow Me Down
Slow
Me
[Music]
Down